so we have the daily grid system this is
so students are supposed to practice you
know online exercises by themselves
before the class and then so we grade
their performance in class based and
then based on the performance like the
best performance is going to be graded
like 10.10 and then if students just
come to class without any preparation
they may get either six or seven
depending on the instructor so daily
grade system is a great incentive for
student to practice outside of the class
or before the class so we had so called
interview test twice for each semester
and what we do is actually one-to-one
kind of interview setting usually like
five to seven minutes again depending on
the level but what we do is teachers
kind of elicit some questions so that
student can answer you know a particular
forms and and grammar patterns so the
interview test we do like five to seven
minutes for each student if you have
like fifty students having interviewed
test itself is actually a lot of work it
we usually spend one day sometimes two
days actually we would like to give
individually feedback on their
performance but that itself again
additional like two to three days we
cannot afford it and so we usually give
just a point not and then if there are
some you know specific issues say like
you know some students are not good at
pronouncing particular words and then we
provide specific feedback otherwise
usually we just spend we just give the
point